justice correspondent Jeff Piquet's is
outside FBI headquarters Jeff good
morning let me ask you about this book
is what strikes you the news that is in
the book or the scathing tone and
judgment from the former FBI director
well all of those things strike me about
this book this is Comey not holding back
he is definitely settling some scores in
this book you know he talks about some
of his interactions with President Trump
especially during that briefing in
January of 2017 before the inauguration
where he was briefing President Trump or
then-candidate or president elect Trump
on the contents of that dossier that was
compiled by the former British spy and
the Russian investigation so there new
details there he's talking about his
interactions with the President and
though he is taking shots at the
president too with these personal
slights talking about his height and
some of his physical characteristic Eric
turistic so this is James Comey
definitely settling some scores here
Jeff what do you think in this book
might be of interest to the special
counsel Robert Moeller well there is a
lot in this book that obviously the
Special Counsel can use in his
investigation but keep in mind he has
already sat down he's talked to James
Comey and Comey is not the kind of
person who would release a book like
this if he knew that it would compromise
the investigation but what investigators
certainly will focus on based on his
account of his interactions with
President Trump is that moment where he
was briefing President Trump also the
meetings in the White House where
according to Comey President Trump asked
him if he would drop the Flint
investigation also that loyalty pledge
so there are several elements in this
book that are pertinent to the rush
investigation well there's a lot of
speculation Jeff about commis future
plans they're announcing the cast of
Dancing with the Stars today I doubt
he's doing that but there's a book offer
any insight as to what he plans to do
well he is someone who is interested in
police community relations he's
obviously worked in government he's
worked for one of the biggest hedge
funds in the world
there is a lot of talk about whether he
will pursue politics as the president
likes to say we'll see alright Jeff
thank you so much